maybe maybe we could we could start our
discussion of sexual differences and
mating strategy with that so first of
all what's the evidence that suggests
that women are in fact choosier when it
comes to sexual partners than men and
how much choosier are they
okay okay great question well so maybe
first we could just define
for listeners what sexual selection
theory is uh because most people when
they think about evolution they think of
survival of the fittest and that sort of
uh nature-written tooth and clock yes
and a kind of a randomness too which you
know that that's kind of implicit in the
natural selection theory where sexual
selection is anything but random
yeah absolutely so so sexual selection
so if if natural selection this is
oversimplified but is um the evolution
of adaptations due to their survival
advantage or the survival advantage that
accrued to the possessors uh so things
like fear of snakes fear of heights
spiders darkness strangers and so forth
food preferences things that led to
better survival sexual selection deals
with the evolution of qualities that
lead to mating success
and darwin identified two causal
processes by which mating success could
occur one is same-sex competition or
intra-sexual competition and the logic
there is that whatever uh he he thought
about it in terms of contest competition
where there was a physical battle like
two stags locking horns in combat
with the victor gaining sexual access to
the female loser ambling off with a
broken antler dejected with low
self-esteem and probably needing some
psychotherapy
but the logic was whatever qualities led
to success in these same-sex battles
whether it be athleticism
uh strength agility cunning or whatever
those qualities get passed on in greater
numbers due to the sexual access that
the victors accrued uh qualities
associated with losing basically bit the
evolutionary dust
the second component so that's
intrasexual competition which actually
the logic is more general than darwin
and vision so like in our species as we
were alluding to
we often compete for position and status
hierarchies uh
and so we we can engage in intrasexual
competition without engaging in this
physical battle or contest competition
although i think that the contest
competition was also part
of human evolutionary history with with
males the other component process is
basically what darwin called female
choice and the logic there is that
whatever qualities if there's some
consensus about the qualities that are
desired
that men possessing the desired
qualities have a mating advantage they
get preferentially chosen those lacking
the desired qualities basically become
in cells or involuntarily celibate they
get shunned banished or ignored
uh now the the twist on that and and so
i think sexual selection is is by far a
more interesting
process and definitely has occurred with
respect to humans
but the twist there is that we have
mutual mate choice at least when it
comes to long-term mating especially i
should say especially when it comes to
long-term mating
uh and and that gets to the issue of uh
trevor's theory of parental investment
where he said he asked the question well
which sex does the choosing which sex
does the competing uh and he his answer
was the sex that invests more
uh in offspring tends to be cheesier sex
that invest less tends to be more
competitive for access to those
desirable uh members of the opposite sex
but in long-term mating
now we know from our reproductive
biology that women have that nine month
pregnancy which is obligatory so women
can't say look i'm i'm really busy with
my career i really only want to put in
three months it's just part of our
reproductive biology
and to produce one child
and men can produce that same child
through one act of sex and so
uh so women are at least in
when it comes to sex the cheesier sex
the higher investing sex in part because
the costs of making a bad mating
decision are much more severe for women
than for men men and women hook up have
sex for one night in the morning they
both realize oh this is a mistake i
shouldn't have done that well if the
woman gets pregnant
then she might be pregnant with a guy
who is not going to invest in her
offspring a guy perhaps is someone that
has poor genetic material
it does not have a robust immune system
etc so so anyway so that's uh that's a
long-winded answer to your question
about uh sexual selection
good so but okay go ahead please go
ahead oh i was just gonna say that the
you asked about the evidence
uh for females being cheesier and they
are cheesier primarily in
the context of casual sex or short-term
sex so that's where you find the big sex
differences and so one of the classic uh
and there is there's a ton of evidence
for this this is a a sex difference that
that i capture in the book under the
category of desire for sexual variety uh
so men have a much greater desire for
meaning a variety of sex partners
than than women do and so
the choosing this comes in
on i'll just give you one experiment
this is a classic study done by
elaine hatfield and russell clark where
they had male and female
confederates which
uh for listeners are members of the
experimental team it doesn't mean people
from the south united states
uh
there
but they had male and female
confederates simply walk up to members
of the opposite sex on a college campus
and say hi
i've been noticing you around campus
lately i find you very attractive would
you and they asked them one of three
questions would you go on a date with me
tonight would you come back to my
apartment with me would you have sex
with me and it was a between groups
designs they simply recorded the
percentage of individuals who agreed to
these three different requests and of
the women
about half about little over 50 percent
agreed to go out on a date with the guy
six percent agreed to go back to his
apartment zero percent agreed to have
sex with him most women need a little
more information
uh
about the guy before they're willing to
have sex uh of the men approach also
about 50 by the female confederate about
50 agreed to go out on the date 69
agreed to go back to her apartment and
75 agreed to have sex with her and so if
you talk about choosing us
um uh are you willing to have sex with a
total stranger who you've met for 30
seconds
uh women
unwilling to
and in general uh men very willing to
and this is a study that's been
replicated now in several european
studies very difficult to do this as you
might imagine to get this by the irbs or
ethics committees in in the united
states anyway um i assume it's similar
in canada or worse
or we're so but
yeah the kinds of studies we really want
to do are more difficult to do nowadays
but it's been replicated in in
several western europe european
countries and you can get women off of
the zero percent you can get a few
percent of the women saying yes if the
guys really really charming
you know if he's a
brad pitt or
or i don't know what the modern
equivalent is ryan gosling or one of the
uh you know or or perhaps a famous rock
star
so um so but that's one illustration of
uh
the answer to your question about well
what is the evidence for female choosing
us now the interesting thing here's i'll
give you one more so there are studies
that ask what is the minimum percentile
of intelligence that you would accept in
a potential partner so and then you and
you know we explain percentiles to
people so they understand 99 percentile
first percentile 50th and so forth and
um and basically for things like a
marriage partner
uh men and women are roughly equal they
both are very exact and they say what
they want like say 65th 70th percentile
intelligence
uh where the sex difference comes up is
just a sex partner a pure sex partner
with no investment
women still maintain they still want
let's say 60th or 60 plus percentile in
intelligence whereas men drop you know
to embarrassing levels that doesn't
really it becomes irrelevant the 35th
40th percentile men go you know if she
can mumble a little bit that's fine or
or even not so um that's another
indication
of female choosiness that is they
maintain
greater choosiness
when it comes to short-term sex
and um
and are simply less comfortable with
having sex with total strangers or
casual sex and
uh
here's i'll give you one more now that
i'm rambling on and then i'll get to
some other uh interesting issues is uh
this is an item on the sociosexuality
inventory that
colleagues uh steve gangstad and jeff
simpson developed a long time ago but
one of the items is that's an attitude
item and it says sex without love is
okay
do you agree with that or disagree with
that and there you get a large sex
difference so in the seven point scale
where four is the midpoint
uh men average about 5.5 so they say yes
sex without love yeah yeah that's okay
uh women are about 3.5 okay they're
below the uh that midpoint it's another
indication um of this sex difference in
choosing this do you know if that's
modulated by big five trait
agreeableness
oh that's a great question i i haven't
seen
any studies that link that okay uh big
five two to that item or the
sociosexuality inventory in general yeah
well you'd wonder why
if compassion and empathy might be one
of the things driving that and the value
that's placed on that as a consequence
of being high or low in agreeableness
and that would fit into some degree with
the dark triad work that because the
primary difference there is we'll talk
about the dark trend in a minute is that
the dark triad types are low and
agreeable to centrally it's not the only
thing but that's central
yeah and that's where there's a big
there's a big sex difference